the strange husband took a machete and
he
took her head off on her shoulders
that was pretty gruesome to say the
least
[Music]
first murderer i ever met was in 1987
where a man murdered his wife
he wanted rabbit and she cooked him
chicken and he stabbed it to death
the man was arrested he was brought into
custody and as the junior
officer on the chef my role was to look
after him to make sure that
he didn't harm himself or anything like
that while she was in custody
to meet somebody that's taken a life is
the
the most bizarre feeling you you're
meeting someone who
10 minutes 15 minutes an hour ago
they've killed somebody that they
previously loved in this
on this occasion so it's quite it's
quite a surreal experience
what happens say for instance you're at
home right it's two o'clock in the
morning you'll get a phone call we've
got a body
you tip out to the office you'd meet the
other guys and you'd go to
an area close to the scene you might not
necessarily go to the scene because the
fact is
the forensics are important in the way
that
they can't be disrupted they have to be
kept intact the integrity of the
um the forensics is paramount in the
investigation so you may not go to this
actually into the scene that will be
left to a chosen few
you'll then undertake house to house if
you've got a suspect
it may be that you're involved in the
taking of swabs from that person
obtaining evidence from that person
removing their clothing
bagging it up correctly making sure it
goes to the exhibits officer correctly
if you're on the interview team you'll
be preparing from the time that you get
in
you'll be reading all the statements
that are available to you you'll be
preparing to interview that person by
the time
you've got to speak to the suspect you
could be 12 or 13 hours into the
investigation before you actually get
into an interview tech stage with them
the process around the prisoner is
fairly straightforward it's the other
work that's taking place in the
background
with the workers if you want they're the
ones that are actually doing all the
work to bring it in and they're bringing
all the jigsaw pieces together
and as an interviewer you're taking that
information and using it as part of your
your your plan around interviewing
i think being a good communicator is the
the greatest technique that you've got
there's no point in being a shrinking
violet if you're sitting in a
in an interview i could write down all
the questions
and and read them verbatim from the
piece of paper but the fact is you've
got to be a free thinker sometimes and
have the ability to communicate
with the person that's sitting opposite
you sometimes you have to empathize with
them
if you've got a suspect that's
as an example murdered a family member
why has he done that
has had things got so bad for that
individual
have they been the victim of domestic
violence is this the last
step that they've undertaken in order to
try and relieve themselves of the
pressures
that they've faced over the past 10 15
20 years
do you ever feel a hatred for the people
you're interviewing it's not my job to
hate somebody
that's not my job my job is to
try and identify for the family why we
are in this situation why
we've got a child an adult
in a in a mortuary the police's role is
to
prove as well as disprove or disprove as
well as prove that somebody's involved
if they haven't done anything wrong then
we'll soon find out they'll be released
from custody but
my job isn't to hate somebody i was
asked a question previously around
is this like the tv it's nothing like
the tv the fact is
that you've got a lot of people working
on one inquiry and it could take
weeks this isn't more so this doesn't
take an hour to clear up
this could take weeks to clear up people
that are working on these different
squads
they sacrifice so much in relation to
their
home lives and what they do in their
personal life
in order to undertake the role that they
do and it is it's fantastic but they are
unsung heroes in my eyes my kids could
tell where i was by the news
not by what their mum was telling me
because they would see oh there's been a
murder in such and said and they knew
what i did
it was their election of my duties as a
father
because it takes its toll i will tell
you a funny story
i went to one where um the lady hadn't
been seen
elderly lady died in her house that was
that was standard practice for um
probationers to go to a sudden death as
we used to call them
and i broke into the house i let my
colleague in there's a lady collapsed on
the bed
and i said oh yeah i called up on the
radio
she's dead and this lady sits bolt
upright and says
i'm not dead i'm not dead all my life
but yeah so you know there are some
funny sides to policing as well
what's some of the worst things you've
seen
um well uh i suppose um the
decapitation of a victim lady was
walking down the street she'd
been she just dropped the kids off at
school just dropped the kids off
and the husband the strange husband took
a machete and he
took her head off on her shoulders um
that was pretty gruesome to say the
least
one one one murder that actually sticks
in my mind was a
where a man from mauritius was was
murdered
he was having an affair allegedly and um
when his family came to see the body in
the mortuary they asked to have a
photograph taken
with him so i had to get permission from
the coroner for them to stand around the
body
and for me to take a photograph of them
as of them
standing around the body giving it the
thumbs up and the big smiles i found
that quite
unnerving let's put it that way um but
yeah there's there's been a few
bits and pieces like that you think well
there's a bit macabre
you know somebody who's been murdered
strangled and then someone has set light
to their house i mean the
necessity and proportionality is bad
enough that they've killed him in the
first place
and that one actually went to a
post-mortem and
the fantastic pathologist um spotted the
the the bone in the in the neck has been
broken the only way that will get broken
is if there had been strangulation
up until that point we didn't know how
he died so
the only way that you would have
sustained that injury is if somebody had
killed you
talk through all these horrific things
why do you do it oh it's brilliant
it is honestly it's i get why people see
it as being depressing i understand that
but you know what if you are
if you are serving the victim to the
best of your ability if you're
supporting the family to the best of
your ability
if you identify the person responsible
and they get convicted at court
you are part of a team that has
successfully brought somebody to justice
for the most horrendous crime
murders of murder as a murder jack the
ripper was doing it in the late
1800s the method hasn't changed it's one
person taking another person's life
[Music]
you